hello
uh right this is my second test
to find out what's working and what's
not
before tonight's proper reading um
hopefully this is working hopefully
it'll be going out on twitch
and it'll be turning up on people's uh
facebook
streams on my page and of course on
youtube
um and my biggest worry
for now because we have one of these
amazing storms here on sky that's
practically american
um is just hoping
that you can hear me um
and you'll be able to hear me tonight
and i'm gonna try
reading something to see what happens
and so this is a very short story and
it's a christmasy story
but it's still appropriate for halloween
i think it's called nicholas was
and it's exactly a hundred words
nicholas was older than sin
and his beard could grow no whiter
he wanted to die the dwarfish natives of
the arctic
caverns did not speak his language but
conversed
in their own twittering tongue conducted
incomprehensible rituals when they were
not actually working
in the factory once
every year they forced him sobbing
and protesting into endless night
during the journey he would stand near
every child in the world
leave one of the dwarves invisible gifts
by its bedside
the children slept frozen into time
he envied prometheus and loki
sisyphus and judas his punishment was
harsher
ho ho
ho okay
now to find out whether this actually
streamed and if it worked
and when i can be heard over the wind
bye